um I'm Isaac France this is Harry Colson
and we are here to crush you we're gonna
destroy you oh that's with our that is
1,300 1,200 level chest go ahead and
challenge us just just remember it says
seeing those chest clip at the bottom
but you're actually playing Isaac and
myself so it's true so you know what
after like pretend you're grandmaster or
anything so I see one challenge from
anti-you
I would love to play you but ten ten is
a little long a little too long we want
to make sure we get lots of games in
with lots of people so let's do between
503 to those types of time controls 323
2 is really good
3 2 is great 5o lets me actually talk to
you guys without flagging both both are
good are we gonna see a 3 oh I'll see
that it's fast let's do it alright
alright
agents arrow let's go let's do it what
sign in what how did that happen what
how does that happen how am I getting
challenges and weeks going on what have
you ever seen this before how did that
happen I accepted a challenge I tried to
play d4 in it and it signed me out
alright alright Danny what's going on
man
Danny's you handled Danny is our
technical adviser here
thanks for waiting agents plastic
deformation trance here I have in fact
never played anything all right there he
goes
have you never seen ever since c4 I hear
the noise yes all right
maybe eventually that night away pins he
smells Annie pond so it's not really
pinned yet well maybe not maybe maybe oh
hey no that night is there do I take
that night I think I do
kind of makes his pawns a little ugly
right a little bit I think I take that I
think and then I think I attack it no
but this hangs my deep bond oh that's
really that's that's no good we
shouldn't have told him that it's like
poker us there we go all right he was so
worried about his loss I didn't see it
good okay all right he's technically
don't lose bishop
don't lose bishop good idea I think I
might do tonight e to to g3 to maybe ask
some questions to this Bishop of where
do you want to go all right I trade
trade I trade trade I Dre you brother
likes trades your brother very
professionals are doing these days
all right do I got two things attacking
you but then the question is does
something nasty happened to my knight
well it's pinned to my queen I think no
because if he attacks it with a pawn
boss I'm attacking his queen that's
right even even if he you know tries to
utilize that pin by doing something
common like attacking it with a pawn you
just take his queen
because Queen oh yeah in this case I
happen to be able to take his queen - oh
you checked me he's gonna try and wreck
me well I don't really want to block
with anything because then he takes
that's right no no no I can block with
my queen because then if he takes mine I
take his queen but if he takes my queen
I take back with my knight
there you go that's why your Isaac Franz
that's why it's why you're part of the
family second in the world
well blazes around he's gained hundreds
rating points there's quite a few
Francis to uh to pick from here all
right how we doing here I think really
do say no I think we're just stuff quiet
I think we're just up a bond okay I
think I have more Center I don't think
anybody really has a lead in development
because we both have one piece let's
move now well you have to now I can have
to kind of do all right the equal equal
game an equal time here but I think your
pawns a little better to Center pawns he
does not I think I'd rather be me yes
and I think this Bishop is that's that's
a good Bishop - yes it's pretty the
bishop pretty good bishop hmm
what squares what I want these I don't
end up on before might not be hideous to
play well I want it yeah I do think I
want to play over here on the Queen side
a lot cuz I think I have but your time
is running so oh yeah time is a factor
go out them attack attack attack attack
get them go get them no harm advantage
on the Queen side why would you move
your piece away from their advantage
that's just me though well we're gonna
go over here it's true that's true I
guess I can I can do I can try and mmm
do something though do something do
something something is better yes do
something something is better than
anything from the DL and then push a
deep on that's what I'm gonna do that
sounds that sounds logical is my C pawns
well week eventually challenges where is
your having any I think I take this I
take these is the words of the chat a
grandma
so on the right on the right that's
that's that's twitch on the Left that's
YouTube so we got both a chest clip at
school we don't vampire chicken to
challenge us want that me the business
yesterday really I it wasn't pretty
vampire chicken is Isaac's brother whose
actual good Ross Bishop's stallion that
beef that that'd be file looks awful
juicy the V file looks awful juice yes
Bishop used to be a lawyer stupid but
not anymore
but not anymore ia my knight is
defending that my pond my bishops
defending that what if I just put what
can I say what if you doubled up your
rooks that's that's kind of a general
idea here I think
he moved his bishop yep I want to
challenge his rook yeah okay whatever
I'm trading running running running nice
[Music]
pick someone low rated like this 15:07
or risky nope how about 1807 very low
rated sunny one two three four five
hello Luc hazard hello ah milord
so what sad is this this is the that's
YouTube okay you can tell the top all
right and this is twitch mmm-hmm okay
alright make sure if they hide everybody
for me because it's alright I don't want
alright again all right my bad alright
let's see attack can I tie it something
myself in here
yeah at the bottom or says say something
or to say something else say something
I'm giving up on you
wait he took that
what's going on over here I got an open
D file okay I try put the rooks on it
all right I got this dark square bishop
that's like annoying thing right here
right in the middle right in the middle
that'll sit here I got checked right
away go back go back
no oh gosh everything's bad all right
King move not the best ill-advised let's
just say the least
attack thankful repetition maybe gonna
come back bring it back bring it on back
all right
Bishop you okay now I can't castle you
saw straight to castles is really
awkward that's a good
[Music]
let's see what the worst position I've
ever seen but then again it's not the
best it's not the worst it's not the
best I've seen better I've seen worse
get out of here
get out of town you can't just got to be
not as bad it seems like now yeah who's
better over there probably him but I
don't know oh now he's way better cuz I
hung my rug
nice goodness everything's fine
everything is just fine alright how to
lock it up just you know lock it up no
progress for anybody to be had that I
have a past pond I guess but not for
long but not for long I don't want to
trade any of my rooks yeah I probably
play Nike for many for years maybe I
gonna do like efore 2d bifida babies see
for I do not want to trade reps oh no oh
checkmate almost no not quite oh gosh
alright this is bad this is bad news
bears
alright defend upon where is your
brother
good game Sonny okay
I like dubby dub I think it wins okay
I like dubby dub blah I think it wins
okay alright that's a good that's a good
move all right come on let's regroup
here all right all right
he says he thinks we're supposed to win
you don't know anything about me let's
do it
I could use a spare key okay then you
have to check maybe twice let's do this
thing
Sparrow King come on spear king
all right bring it on bring it on
develop some Knights develops Bishop's
yeah very classic Joe very classic very
calm very reserved watch out for the
fried liver but he didn't play it so the
fried liver is not a believe in the
fried liver it's not a mistake open my
liver sauteed nah nothing good I don't
think I have anything good going here
what happens if i push this pawn to the
close the position down possibly my
pushes pawn and then but if you push if
you push I take my shrimp he takes
Knight then you could take his pawn you
like take on g2 or something no no oh no
that's right all right this was I think
I'm stealing I think so this I think I
want it yes I think so too
let's see and we could play your Bishop
play your attack attack just when in
doubt attack when in doubt yes exactly
we brother always told me just develop
your stuff and I'm hanging your pieces
and you should be okay somebody must
write clearly a widow motion for black I
don't know about clearly but this
position is winning for black chess club
super bulges who wrote that from the
Chess Club Super Bowl just causes
traffic and is annoying for us to live
next to it you concentrate on the game I
don't know man I don't know okay got it
god I was Danny Machuca I was our
awesome technical advisor chess player
extraordinaire Danny Machuca I believe
that's his official title where is he
does he have some crazy night moves that
I'm scared of no actually I don't want
to have that bishop anymore that's all I
know
oh okay don't don't move that rook
whatever you do because it's defending
he put a queen there and I don't want it
there anymore go away go away Queen
nobody invited you move it nobody
invited you okay this how about some
time attacking position even me so weak
squares are you weak squares I go here
and then I threaten the sack on a ch3
gene oh my god that's gonna do you
though me neither oh [ __ ] probably not
enough support over there I don't have
enough on a fire power over there per se
what if I tuck a bishop on this diagonal
and I'm attacking over here and then
that's not bad and then and then maybe I
can sacrifice one of those pieces he's
tachy
okay somewhere other than where it is so
better much better maybe it's like some
activity over here with these pawns but
I just thought what to do with them what
do I do with these pawns um you're
you're correct monster hunter unite not
hanging pieces is so hard what about
putting your rook on the C file and
pushing those pawns may be caused some
consternation center all right all right
I'm down I'm game I am hip to the hop as
they say please stop attacking my Queen
sir nobody nobody asks for this all
right I didn't okay we got so many
places to go
just rooks just rooks that's what I get
for putting a Brook in a queen on the
same your brother would lambaste you yes
wasted like a lamb no no he's gonna put
his knight back and attack my queen
again I got to put my queen somewhere
where it's just not getting attacked
like over here this puts pressure on a
rook and upon it's true it's true I got
some pressure on this guy here this is
still a thing there's some button for
like undo all errors are not my friend
okay
hopefully the chat helps me a lot yes I
need all of the help I can get Sarah
firm one to make sure to tell me very
fast too because what is our time
control euro it's five oh okay cool no
it was like three oh and I only spent so
little time attacking your queen again
but what if I take a rook and attack his
Queen that's what I was thinking so hey
so I take rookie takes Queen I took
Queen he takes bishop I have I think
you're better to minors I think you
better all right I think so too because
I get an extra pawn at the end and I
have like at us three on two sure you
move your queen okay so okay this pawn
is hanging yes but then this will be
hanging here but if you move to your
tacking use alright I got I get a double
attack on this rook here through this
nice line here totally calculated right
the two men go to body has left cuz
could a checkmate earning but I will
have a piece at the end of this this is
true this is true you want to take that
you want to take that take that I will
have a piece good job Isaac anybody in
chat who's been here game I see somebody
saying play add row 81 add row 81 do I
see you in the list here there he is
81 bring it on good do it bring it on
what's a drill gonna play what you got
what do you got a drew what you got for
me ah ah D for my four move I gotta
remember to not put my hand here oh it's
so hard to not do it just feels
comfortable for you guys feel yes I want
to stress my beers and yes I understand
think like Abe Lincoln kind of what you
think in abling you know alright in a
bishop a lot of our presidents played
chess I don't know if the I think it's
like is that I think it's because in tip
and in general
smart people play chess in general most
of them in general and that's all I'm
gonna say about that a little disclaimer
do not talk politics here on the stream
alright we've been we've been muted
already Danny muted us I just push all
my pawns why Judas Danny troublemaker
we're not talking politics whatever we
never done this before I kind of wish I
didn't oh I want him to trade any of
those pawns so I can put my knight on c6
I would like my c6 pawn to become either
a d5 or b5 fun all right he chose d5
cool now I have a square for my knight
but then again where is this Knight
really going his necks a little
bothersome there there's night it's
night I would say a grill a little
bothersome so I'm gonna see if I can
trade it with our knight a little
rerouting trade wheel of traits trait Oh
a very professional trade trade trade I
would have developed a bishop but that's
just me through one of every joke on it
you could have thrown upon possibly
where now you can't it's too late now
but we're here right here but still good
spot for it looks like right I believe
it does look hideous
what happens if I just make a queen
battery and try and checkmate him and he
doesn't see it coming that would be
awesome
this dude isn't running away is he just
like is he running ah running good job
the job's not over but it's it's not
over but let's do some of this and then
if he steps over there do I just take
this guy should I'm gonna take that guy
out yeah or not I think things have
gotten a little out of here I don't have
for a drill
are we still muted Danny probably all
right all right let's make sure I don't
mess this up all right I can just be
like cheapo grab some pawns or I can try
do it don't grab that pond well not this
one okay definitely not that ran grab
this one but like a better chess player
would probably do something better so
I'm gonna pretend that I'm one of them
okay and I'm gonna get give this night
involved I think that's a better idea
and then also just just to let you know
your King still is in the middle of the
board it's true but I don't see how many
of his pieces like no but you know
something to consider consider okay
tonight up in there my knight is I would
like to say yes in your grille right
Knight is in your grille oh that's not
over but it's Pleasant okay I agreed not
over but I'd rather be me
I'm kind of fine with lots of these
files opening up a bit if I can keep
this diagonal closed we're like a put
this little EEP on you can never check
me with this Queen any good stuff all
right look I rook is more involved than
he used to be
yes and the Queen can't come to any of
these like squares got em all oh they're
all mine and then you can double up your
rook and you can win a rook I can double
up a rough winter oh yes I mean that
could have actually done that this turn
just what my queen could probably hmm I
don't know but this one's like gives
more activity with a threat who knows
what's better our Grand Master probably
alright you can definitely win her up
now I mean can I like checkmate though
it's like didn't kind of close if you're
gonna move anything I would move the
rook because then he's gonna block with
his bishop don't go there no don't go
there
check with your rook there's he blocks
with his bishop move your queen and then
it's well I think I take the Queen take
the Queen why not
and then um you know he's attacking this
but I don't really care we should care
you don't we just drop a piece for no
reason but his rooks on the other side
of it so it's kind of pinned that's true
so I'm gonna pin his knight who's King
they donate here
always trans good always they want to
trade always trade one of our awesome
bloggers here whatever you call them
said all these two thirteen hundreds are
playing like a sixteen hundred combined
[Music]
take my play fast take my R up dude
that's my advice does not belong to you
fast
that's move just do something he's gonna
get back we check maybe I can't do it
okay just making sure
can't all right oh it's a technical
check and check them fast fast I'm gonna
get like super duper mated here it's
gonna moon oh I made it
no I'm actually made it good game good
good job finding that made to the end no
not rematch other game alright well
that's embarrassing
super duper won a game then super duper
lost it sounds pretty standard for me
ma'am so many challenges all right
Nicholas leskew I've seen this name
before have you I've seen it before
I'm sure I'll see it again never really
never know in this crazy game we call
chess I play these three moves almost
every time almost every if it unless my
opponent doesn't let me i play d4 c4
Knight c3 like every game I've played
you hundreds of games and that's what
you play yes unless you forced me to do
otherwise
alright there's a knight there I didn't
have a love/hate relationship with chess
I think so you know pretty standard is
that standard
that is how it goes take with your
Center Pond I just want to mention to
our viewers Danny are we unmuted of
course but we gotta be unmuted right
okay so also on okay I would have
mentioned to our viewers that if you
want to send in one of your games for
our GM to analyze tomorrow night it's a
show we do that our GM does it's called
analyze your games if you want to send
your game to it's called the analyzer
games those viewers choice excuse me
it's called viewers Choice viewers
choice send your game to info at State
Lewis chess club org and make sure to
include whether you are black or white
and whether you've won or lost and also
don't forget to send your games I've had
some viewers actually yeah they sent me
an email
there's no game you know so send your
games to viewers choice at st. Louis
chess club dot org info at st. Louis
chess club org
all right include the information that
we need and we'll have a grandmaster
analyze your game it's fun stuff all
right what's going on over here Isaac
well how we doing I think we're doing
relatively okay okay I don't think we're
losing well that's always good it's
always a step in the correct direction
hi prodigal elpizo how are you today
we're gonna stream probably till what at
least 4:30 4:30 4:30 ish 4:30 at the
minimums right and then if I'm winning
all of my games longer put it right
there
eyes will go running toward the parking
lot crying all right if you want to make
a chess player cry I am the one to do it
although Isaac is a good sport he's a
good sport
and he's a good person too hey thanks
man you're welcome welcome all right
you're a Good Man Charlie Brown I try
all right where we at he's gonna put
this night like up in my face
right up in your grill honey let's find
out if he does okay I like that right
there
Oh oh no he's gonna fork me oh he might
no actually I mean interesting stuff
happens if you force me some interesting
stuff could happen okay just just get
the four possibility out of there okay
all right
that's an interesting move I can't be
forked anymore dude no but it's an
interesting move can't be forked anymore
trying for just try just try to do it
just try and do it he takes I take he
moves Knight I played a knight he here
to block the Queenie action and then
eventually I try and take with the rook
on each six that's my plan
hey man why assume he's gonna move his
knight to attack my queen a man without
a plan you know a man without a plan is
not a man it's not a man yeah yeah whoa
got to have a plan I'm a man hear me
roar numbers too big to ignore
that's a Helen Reddy song from the 70s
year that was my plan okay
I mean he could take but that was a heck
of a plan I don't like threatening me
and I'm threatening rip takes here oh
good job good job good job good job
Nicholas thanks for the game that was a
pleasure to do tat all those challenges
player 18:53 he's got a stupid name
stupid nicknames
alright alright here's I just dumped
susima we actually gonna see the players
name is up there now I think we used to
not be able to do that really yeah whoa
what's going on what do you you're gonna
do some get out of here go away I just
don't want any nights our bishops coming
to g5 hitting Han I'm currently up a
pawn but he was trying to do something
crazy well you know stupid nicknames
that's pretty strong montre pawns a
strong West rape on student
all right what's going on here well the
game and I'll suspend Jambi on stream no
being our YouTube channel but it might
be premiered we've started doing a new
thing where we premiere classes as they
come out as their they actually happen
live so a Tuesday 6:30 lecture such as
I'm not sure if much of what time those
lectures are but they're either Tuesday
or Thursday or something of the like to
walk with night they end up premiering
at the same time that the lecture
happens so they're kind of live kind of
streamed but you can't you know see you
can't talk to the lecturer as it's
happening or anything like that alright
he's attacking this pong still is I
don't
so where can I move my do I have any
squares I can move my bishop that also
defend that pawn no but I have one that
generates a threat which is kind of like
defending kind of kind of okay I trade
my trades okay and now I need to either
defend this pawn or what if I attack I
mean a threat oh that hangs its Knight
though no poker okay say Knight but I
wrote oh my goodness it's chaos dude
where's going in we're in in for a penny
in for a pound you know we're we're in
it to win it
[Music]
yeah there's no way for me like trap
this night afterwards so yes that's
better because at least you could just
trade at least get something out of you
know otherwise we just lost that night
straight up I think this way I go down
in exchange instead of being down like a
piece right maybe Danny's also been
there like pulling his hair out
it'll say if you could attract his pawn
you could I mean his knight you could
take it away to try his Knight I could
have like taken that and then tried to
get the knight back later but I didn't I
didn't see any of that that goodness
happening I believe in a certain type of
Creek without any pedals right but you
know what we don't give up here at the
chess club never surrender to d3 cuz you
for can use Brooks oh right I'm black d3
is way up here it's right yeah I wish I
could play 93 well that would be awesome
so good so professional I don't want to
trade but I'm doing it not particularly
pleased but I did it's a moment okay how
to make sure I don't like lose all these
pawns though I don't know if he moves
his rook off that thing I could get to
attack one of his pawns
there you get your King into action I
don't know okay King King moose also had
some real validity yes I'm gonna get my
King a little bit more involved
there you go get more involved King we
need you all right at some point I'm
there's totally gonna be a fork there's
a check though it's a check nonetheless
takes a little time officers clock don't
make you think stupid nickname
I'm coming here he's never gonna see
this - this never never never
there's no way he also doesn't move his
king and rook is he's gonna push a pawn
totally I got this always repeat always
repeat very professional how about this
guy yeah there you go
now I can play 94 it's very clear but I
can play that before but I don't really
want to work to come here this is true
it's kind of smooth this is true play
your jeep on then no I Rock d8 is maybe
good I don't know the kind of less is
rook into the position
you know a little bit you know he's in
he is in like Flynn we're in check yes
there's a check therefore it is a check
so therefore it is I need to threaten
upon as well
ah that's check twerk lifeguard that's
you yeah somebody's must be spectating
me from the accounts or something don't
don't go up cuz then he checks you and
takes another poem with tempo alright
alright alright alright
okay and you teeth take what is pug I
wouldn't say no cuz its offended by a
row it is that's why I asked oh just ask
quickly you know there's no such thing
as stupid questions all these dancers
know just the stupid people that ask
them words words words quickly is not
looking the greatest I've seen better
chess positions
oh alright stupid nicknames good game it
was a pleasure and an honor to fight you
I will play you in Valhalla okay Perry
is not I've got a play blunder central I
need I need I need to play against some
lenders burn Perry is crush it's not
playing
Isaac Francis all Isaac and Friends
as I am arrow is emotionally
I meant emotionally alright alright
who's this is not necessarily
recommended but I do it sometimes do we
know who Luke D hazard is nope D is his
middle initial though did he learn chess
from fight comer that's funny then
Feingold will be proud Shroud she
literally taught me everything you know
about the Banco let me taste it I taught
you nothing okay I think he's talking
about Jonathan my brother Jonathan
Sean's has taught you plenty but anybody
who learned from me
had the wrong teacher what's going on
over here stuff and thanks blogger
central nice name
he's a good name that is a good name
crazy that'd be nice could you just take
that wouldn't it but there's bishops
like two good special too strong
I think I want this diagonal to open up
all right
it I consider that an open diagonal now
can I get my knight involved if anything
that's going on over here I don't know
give a shot let's give her the old
college try
hmm stand the college tribe it's gonna
be like not a lot of effort would be the
college try all right I don't want him
to attack that so I'm gonna give it
because that's a power of Bishop there
I'm gonna say doing the things he's
doing the stuff and the thing he's a
bishop for made to do absolutely the
bishops were made for walkin never play
f3 whatever our viewer says well good
thing I played f5 we have awesome
viewers that's all I got to say yes such
knowledgeable excellent viewers here all
of our viewers are grandmasters in fact
well let's not go overboard but they're
awesome viewers that's for sure if
you're in this chat you're a grandmaster
awesome of twitch chat this is true I
have a lot of pressure on this guy here
you really do and this guy is like kind
of pinned awkwardly a little it's not
like he's not like really pinned but
he's kind of pinned see what happens
here I mean if he takes your Jeep on you
just took right back then he's he did
I'm going for the Hakeem on a cone to Ma
Tei you guys are smashing this one
through he thinks he has see what
happens does this have the Danny seal of
approval that's the question
what right that's what we're asking yes
nice and a little nope that's why you're
Danny Machuca but I looked at me taking
that trade straight no trade okay that's
right apologize some checks that's right
you have some checks good job this looks
a little unpleasant
what happens if not watching Chester
just want you to check out who the two
people are on stream are they are
Isaac's rods and Perry Coulson's Isaac
transcend Perico is the entertainment
today see we are I'm being very generous
with that term entertainment no it's not
Queen Queen protected okay that's why I
went over here to attack this guy well I
mean this F pawn is debatably hanging
yes pieces but if you could somehow get
that rook involved I'm gonna go to f3
just in case I want to put a knight here
I don't think I do because my Knights
defending this austere saralyn would say
he's an arrow that's what the Oster
calls bishops saying go this way that's
right
look at this blunder central he's taking
a lot of his time he doesn't know how to
defend this pawn I mean he's got to play
one of these right guys right he's got
to move something to that rank hey Danny
do you know the remove all arrows button
on HS there's anybody in chat know it
let us know if you know remove all
arrows button on Li Ches
let's see how many siblings please
Lorenzo the youngest of two just just
Jonathan and I Lorenzo wants us to play
him so I assume is that
Isaak at GM uses GM in my heart he's a
gem in my heart all right I am closer to
GM and league of legends than I am in
but he's a GM in life okay
he's attacking this now that pawn is
hanging but I'm attacking this I applied
another attacker to that pawn you have
lots of attackers which maybe
spooksville for our opponents maybe not
though who knows but he moves his rook
up do I just up checkmate yeah he moves
his rook up to defend that pawn I
intercept checkmate so I don't see how
he well I guess he has three defenders
of it no he is - he has a king and a
queen I don't see though yeah it's a
third all right now left-click and it
gets removed draw arrows that's a
victory a great victory for the chess
club here with Isaac's France at the
controls I don't know that'll do him
well I'm just making arrows cuz it's
okay it's fun to make arrows okay
blunder central is just letting his time
it's a tough position quickly it is not
easy for him to play nobody wants to do
nobody wants to like lose no of course
not alright that's okay that's okay
good game blunder central ok I can play
rook takes take Queen I can play Queen
takes he has to go rook takes he goes if
I go if I go Queen takes a real takes
rook takes is like the for sure super
duper easy win but is there like some
other crazy checkmate if I do Queen
takes no I don't think so okay I'm just
gonna try and take a queen and win from
there
I think the key that whole game was that
Bishop down there Gigi put the games
central good game what a good sport that
was that was a good sport plunder
central challenges no play um Lorenzo
didn't you see believe you said play
with Lorenzo Lorenzo Dhoni Otto alright
well I assume it's miss Lorenz olds okay
probably renzo LDL yes I think you're
right is this the Lorenzo that I also
know as Sampson this is that I don't
know no wonder he just asked us nicely
saw Damien P likes hot chickens ah I ate
a bunch of spicy chicken something or
other elasticated
hot chicken wings how are they know uh
like frozen spicy patties oh that's a
very very Bachelor of me
well I supposed to be my roommate and I
never saw him cook anything actually
there you had to turn the stove on for I
think it is true might be true I think
you made some rice once I think one time
- you made some chicken so there was the
time I had a canned chicken oh yeah you
remember some rice veggies and canned
chicken
no that's gourmet of the gourmet variety
Lorenz was coming down and you stopped
it in a hot yes coming in hot but what
if I attack a queen tuk queen what do
you feel about that
Lorenzo like that are you like them
apples let's see alright now I think I
get to trade my knight for a bishop
mayhaps treat a knight for a bishop I
mean am I gonna trade a knight for a
bishop all good things
Oh your brother would love that he just
thinks bishops are were so much more
than Knights but because they are well
you know that's debatable
that is debatable Fair Master said it
must be true ah Grand Master said it
must be true okay I heard it from the
Grand Master what's going on here heard
it straight from the horse's mouth
what's going on all right it's written
that guy I want him to go oh well what's
your Jacqueline go away nobody invited
you don't take my thing I'm over here
and I put it on b7 and then push this
guy and that bishops can be really
strong right oh no he's got some stuff
going on no happens to the best of us
buddy hunger queen good game Lorenzo
come gamer Enzo oh my queen many many
times it won't be our last one that's
right who's the highest rated game no if
we played zone P today oh my so P stuff
won't be stuff all right
all right so P here you want some rating
rights what are we bad you're 400 points
higher than me see why dopey you never
played a Sicilian Isaac ever never
played a never play the Sicilian no if
they play before I play did you just
avoid the Sicilian at all cost
I picked those things because they were
easy to remember I know it's the same
kind of sharp it's a little shame and
when you're a novice slash beginner I
know that's really matter I just take an
opening I should probably stop pick an
opening you can remember and won't mess
up all the time I surprise top play this
whenever there's a queen here I always
forget it's attacking that thing and
then I go attack it yeah don't do that
yep don't do that all right I am going
to fianchetto this pitcher okay just
play smart little moves Isaac smart
little moves don't remain crazy yeah a
professional try anything crazy
what are you how am I gonna have fun
doing it I know but just be mellow be
mellow
we'll get your piece develop your pieces
develop that bishops are now developed
there you go Color Me develop that's
right you know what don't do that don't
move back and you lose him don't do that
there you go all right you know what
this pawn is hanging so I'm gonna defend
it all right with the castle with a cast
that's pretty good move it's pretty good
move cuz I'm dead king of the castle all
right came in to castle now he's
attacking your stuff a little bit but
taking stances a little bit I'm going to
how could you
night war in action I'm gonna go here
right there okay oh right there all
right
it's closer to the center it is a bad
thing if you could dislodge that Bishop
somehow on e3 that would be great but
I'm gonna need to he cancelled on that
side so I think I need to like start
pushing playing on these all these guys
just joking though do something do
something don't you worry
something's happening see we get that
rook on the C file somehow I don't do
any good
move quickly Isaac no quickly no ah h5
that always popular move I am trying to
play h5 just trying to stop that pawn
rush playing h5 yep I don't want him to
have any funds malarkey going on over
there malarkey anything to see I'm
attacking this square that's counter
Perry he's going one two three three
things three pieces three chess pieces
attacking that square alright he's
trying to attack me over there I'm
trying
Knight is under attack guys it's true
okay I was planning on wearing my knight
there I know I didn't put it on the e5
actually but that's just me uber mated
I'm SuperDuper mated like like super
duper made it here yeah no that's
illegal
I can't go there no cuz there's this
Queen that you're not seeing I see it
and if I push up if I push up on he just
checked me it's me I'm gonna go with
this is bad news like here
I don't you check mated on this turn if
I do this and then you could trade
Queens and you'll be down but you will
be checkmated I like not being
checkmated I know I'd rather lose some
the way the meat checkmated so some of
this boy me but now that's not checkmate
so I don't know Zofia stuff you could
check them no you can't check them sopia
stuff you're down down two points only
um I do not want to take that bond by
the way know what if you what if you
weigh it was my queen attacked no why
did I even move my queen I didn't have
to quite sure okay no not really no he's
like super duper duper trouble this is
like a lot of checkmate happening salty
is tough this is not a small amount of
check knives okay before he's the only
one that doesn't get me checkmated has
taken there with a queen right hmm that
only saves me for our turn as well
mm-hmm well I just I just call it a good
game he's tough sopia stuff is open easy
took two rating points from us storm to
halt rainy points wait we got here who
should you play let's go with Eduardo
Jodi says it's a unique way of spelling
Eduardo its kind of it sounds like it
weren't right all right I wonder if
that's an actual Williams right there's
your fingers get a little uh I wish I
had like my nice mouse from home Danny
has his crazy good mouse this mouse is
of the not good variety what's going on
develop your stuff don't have anything
what can you move all these pieces and
not hang them okay look at me go oh I
can't be stopped
stop it go away and I just want to
mention to all of our members and
viewers to Friday night is the Friday
night action quads come on down and test
your skills against people of your own
level it's really fun tournament you're
gonna play three quick rainy games it is
really fun I mean if you're if you just
get started at chess long time control
sound very daunting right twenty minutes
with three second delay come down please
people of your own your own ilk and it's
a good time it's a good time come down
you can crush me
I'll be here make sure to take one
because with the bishop here any plays
Knight here it's really awkward because
this night has bins don't get pinned
wait what oh this guy's attacked twice
now mmm interesante
but isn't it I mean is it kind of just
trades is the problem the ropes the real
ouch
but what if I come back with some very
manly sacrifices I think you should do
it do it yeah just do it just be a man
about it let's do it cuz if he takes
back I think I can have at least a draw
take it look at that right I think I
might have to settle for a draw here
though no I don't have that either even
or what if I do this I think that'd be a
good move do it I think he moves his
rook then he just moved here then you
just move Bishop to f6 but the question
is where does he move his rook I guess
rook f7 gives a decent amount of
resistance still get that get that night
in action yeah my promise my pieces
aren't doing anything of the sorts who
this is like look link says you should
have developed your Knights that's
probably the better probably true you
know it's builders as you sound a lot
like
your brother that's true yeah we have
very serious voice oh gosh I lose game
over let me get in there once you want
you let me get in again that's gonna
break um hold on though cuz your mic is
there hey Danny you want to lower our
mics for a second while we change them
out
you
you
all right
the old man here all right let's see
what's going on here we use good then
Mike nice and pointed your mouth yeah
you're good are we good
Oh Jonathan's telling me to kick me out
oh gosh
Jonathan said kick you out Jonathan
kicked me out good game Eduardo I don't
know how to pronounce your name but good
game all right let's see who we got who
wants to play let's see is this what's
going on here with this that's someone
too crazy
how about Rebecca Rosa the HDMI cable
got pulled out all right I'm on it
just kidding it's back all right Rebecca
Rosa
how about Rebecca all right let's play
Rebecca all right Rebecca it's your move
all right
new planet Isaac can't you've never plan
t bring it show me the record show me
the tape plenty I disagree 90 of times
okay oh we could play right now
checkmate me already
is that what you're doing what is going
on with this uh scrolling oh here scroll
IDO II I'm trying to interact with you
twitch chat but it is Wow she's trying
to checkmate me it's the craziest thing
I've seen today trade just like work all
right Isaac you know I hope he loses
Yankee to my cables we don't have to
watch someone say that on their stone
their stream it was Jonathan did he
really
you said it to you like a big meanies
mean he is mean jump mated night on e8
never made
I have ideas fried liver truth is well
the fried liver is good but doesn't it
require your opponent to play bad like
you so you get the fried liver position
isn't it good but your opponent should
never let you oh my goodness maybe the
shadowy AV guy should play some games I
don't know he's kind of scared of twitch
chat alright yep as that other as that
other STL chess club member said that
guy is bad at chess who's the better
France at chess
oh that's Jonathan ah der quit says he's
like a funnier Jonathan haha I know
you're at home watching very funny he
just has a dry sense of humor Jonathan
yeah Jonathan would do great unlike a
British panel shows a dry sense of humor
very dry too dry sense of humor where we
out here does anybody play each other on
leech s to streaming simultaneously I
don't really ever see that maybe there'd
be something fun to do where we do like
a company tournament or something and we
stream it that would be fine yeah we
almost did that last time but some
players chickened out towards the end
there yeah that that's an idea Luke
[Music]
also metruff answers your question
Derrick but Jonathan is much better than
me probably 500 600 points stronger than
me there'll be pretty fun Luke I think
we should do that we did something
similar where we we had a company
tournament but unfortunately we didn't
save our game here I don't know he
trades he trades Queens and then checks
you with a rook and takes your bishop
what's this guy Isaac's rating my rating
is like 1350 or something but I bet if I
played 100 or so games I could average
out about 1,500 like it learns nothing
but just played a bunch of games
probably the 1500 issue what do you do
just Castle last tournament I played was
like a year ago and I I beat a 1600 drew
a 1700 and lost to an 1800 really yeah
Wow a tournament between everyone at the
Chess Club yes guys must be pretty good
at just I'm wondering if the llama Lord
was here for that tournament
did he participate in said tournament ah
that guy is pretty good at chess who's
the most famous chess player either of
y'all have played well you know in a
real game you're in like just for
funsies I played Yasir Sara Juan I
played Katarina Nemcova
I played Dennis poor oh Sh my poke my
probably most star-studded chess moment
was when I got to play bug house with
Levon Aronian mvl and Fabiano's coach
ruse Tom I was playing against roost on
his partner was mvl and my partner was
oh you're certainly checkmate here no
we're fine
you have so many things attending that
Square okay I had a lot of fun playing
that game but Levon Aronian did not okay
um why didn't you take his pond with
your night we're gonna go check I just
don't like yeah I don't wanna get
checkmate
you have a king and two rats attacking
that's making sure okay okay go Perry
you're the best ice cream vampire chick
trying
I agree don't let me give no you have I
could discover my knight attack the
bishop if it was your turn Knight f4
right here wins right yeah never before
there's a Rebecca Rosa girl shot I wish
it was
Rebecca Buffington awesome Events
Coordinator she's awesome lady she's out
all week oh yeah she worked so hard
around here she is
I'm Jerry yeah just for fun W Bennett
I've played Yasir Sarah in a few games
i've played blitz against Fabiano I've
played blitz against Levon Aronian won
game play bug house with mvl as well
good day we lost the HDMI again what's
that mean it means we don't actually see
the board hey Danny cut Mike no one saw
me win this game
oh it's back its back all right one for
the chest goes like out rate is okay
make sure Oh rising of penguin what's
your rank one we go one for the Chess
Club did the new season just starts I
haven't done this season but my highest
rank ever was plat one how about a happy
pond let's play a happy pie I've lost
diamond promos twice I think you were
good and I do it I won with the Sicilian
that open line and everything rising of
penguin do I know you how do you know
that I play League of Legends what are
you doing are you trying what are you
doing you try to attack wave my stuff
without your doing that's right are they
twins they look so much alike we are not
quite twins the main difference is that
my beard is familier and redder I think
he might dispute that fact he's gone a
much much less man here with a 1492 and
a question mark so
I know so let's just develop our pieces
and see I did say I played league of
legends earlier we have very astute
listeners don't you guys are paying more
attention to what I say to me very
sturdy I'm certainly closer to a GM in
League of Legends so chicken see me win
that game
did he just a second what does LM mean
LM means lie chess master li chess
master it's just a special title they
give to people who play a lot on Li
chest squeeze through a lot so they
decided to grace our account all right
what control are you playing that we
have a question mark
yes but plywood is not close to GM but
plat one is closer to GM then 1300 is in
GM so I'm just gonna take the advice of
my really good friend Jonathan France
closer my close friend Jonathan
restaurants develop my pieces that's the
simple things that's step one step one
in chess what champ / role do you mean I
play a lot of Renekton top lane mostly
League of Legends yes this is a chess
stream users dream that doesn't exist at
all this is true position here developed
we're castled oh maybe I can just have
you go like this type to them so that
I'm not yeah yeah yeah alright
are we out here okay so this is that's
why it's 1563 it's a different time
control what the question marks so if we
win this game we can bump our reigning
up quite a bit
your iron bronze your iron such bronze
and thirteen to fifteen hundred in chess
which one am i closer to well between
the two of us were probably about
fifteen hundred with the both of our
minds right now probably something like
that I would imagine yeah
yeah I can give you my nickname go ahead
and invite me have you turned Mario yuck
alright it's the same as my leach s name
and every other game name I've ever made
at least since college
what are you doing here attacking my
stuff
I'm just gonna push you back more and
more and more I agree
bjx 13 is a dingus I don't know what
that means but it sounds funny it is
true it sounds funny happy pond all
right where we at here at the pond what
are you trying to do to me what do you
get if you cross an elephant and a rhino
I don't know I can't say that that's
that is a swear word
I think it's I'm not gonna try and
pretend like I just understood what you
just said if you play chess okay hey do
you take that pawn and then he takes me
let's do it and it's like not a bad
diagonal for your Bishop you know it's a
beautiful diagonal I've so bad eyes on
his each pawn but also try to line these
guys how do you facepalm a keyboard
because there's a face palming hitting
I've seen like face roll like this
vampire chicken watching probably
alright so he's not berating me so I'm
just so blessed to have to Frances in my
life that's all I got to say I'm blessed
all right he's talking my stuff I hear
the bjh 13 is a good mother mr. bishops
first he's talking my stuff let's play
threatens a queen you can move your
money in Southeast that's a tasty night
square I think they're tasty can't be
attacked by any pause for a second
you've got one piece looking at your
king that's long enough seems like more
than that don't you I do like that part
I do like that it was vampire chicken a
big supporter yes
vampire chicken is awesome but watch out
he will wait no so he doesn't like
vampire eyes chicken no he's actual
states that is a BAM he doesn't like so
do vampire
chickens only go after other chickens I
got we safe from the vampire chick he
does not have the taste of human blood
these are chickens no longer watching
because he doesn't wanna have to see
this one you're going through oh really
um but he is listening to us from the
other in the other room
I'd like they gonna take that phone or
no well it wasn't the point of what we
did earlier yes it was
Thank You mr. shrine that's my partner
Jonathan tribes I mean what if I buy our
chicken I think you get vampire rabies
that's something I don't even want to
think about the worst kind of rabies
they are the worst
all right I like our position here yeah
yeah I I kind of almost want to move our
night our other night this guy into that
right here swear position right here
that just looks like a good place where
you're anchored by two ponds I mean
that's the name of the game in it yeah
it's like blocking a lot of squares the
bishop would want to go to maybe you
need to do like an H push first to like
stop his Bishop from coming in but I
don't this guy I don't know he's got it
down on time too I can H push all the
way there like to there I just tacked on
my stuff so when Ben Feingold says Rufus
and doofus is he referring to you guys
in general yes nice pacifically but we
certainly qualify as a ruthless and a do
yes we do yes we do okay two in a row
that would be my record cuz I got
crushed the other day I was filling in
for a my partner here Isaac and they got
crushed you got stuck in traffic or
something I did there was a stalled car
you might as well be walking that's
right cuz it's horrible on Kings Highway
if there's any kind of traffic problems
alright a happy pawn what's going on
here do I just wanna trade up in time
oh no I think I like that bishop so
let's yeah we'll trade those nights oh
definitely and then you can take back
with the seat with the C pod absolutely
yeah or the D or the e pawn then take
this file with my rope yeah but I don't
think you want that backwards C pawn
afterwards what we should we should just
play like McCall tall
I'm sorry take his Bishop is a feat a
master a very good rating yes few
masters are we got a fork we work sorry
happy pawn tasty tasty sorry happy pawn
I know that's really occupying some
squares here I could agree thank you and
then you're not getting mated yeah who
say those are playing squares the llama
Lord well I'm the Lord Allah the Lord
there's Chinese good chefs on fides
online I don't believe so I'll show a
little check just cuz I can and if
there's any ever way to like trade
Queens I think that's in your favor
Thank You llama Lord if you ever takes
your pawn you take his with check in
fact in this situation this bond is kind
of into a rope so I don't think he wants
to take that probably not
does FINA they have their own online
arena server I don't know if they do
they might but it would be like a
separate rating there's no way would I
be actual feed a rating I assume there
is too strong I agree I'm just take
stuff to take stuff and take more stuff
I've been meaning now you're fine with
trade and you're up and you're attacking
a knight and right I am I am pushing
baby
I agree Luke push only now you're
attacking a rope and a clean background
check maybe kami
okay you gotta you just barely I mean
you just happen to have another it's
close I suppose also you could have like
at some points to push the power I'm not
taking that cliff or something oh do you
know this checkmate checkmate
oh no it's not checking no just kidding
I thought you I thought your file is
open and it's not
it's a feed a rating where you can earn
an online title it's a big joke to the
chess community mm-hmm good joke I
laughed yeah all the way over there that
looks tasty
I would go with Queen d8d one personally
Chloe do you want
you've lost Internet oh no Queen D Wan
trade I would offer trades all right
trades ville mm-hmm and then I feel like
moves his king you for clicking and know
if he was the king you just take the
Queen the trade yeah this looks like
you're gonna have a rook and he won't
just check him with my rook I would go
Queen I would go Queen check on D -
that's because it's like I think it's
just the most forcing queen D for was
better Queen D for was better according
to the Lama Lord no according to chess
jack that's all right good good
I'm sure playing with this happy pot one
more in Blake Blake opponent click upon
opponent north component yeah I'm fine
there he is playing right all right he's
been he's been asking for a game along
what's up component good luck man play
well play well all right make your move
all right next game is senior aboard one
that's probably gonna be me taking a
particular always playing the London
system oh my goodness no you're done for
your oh my goodness you've never
explained the London system you've never
been more in trouble you better know
what you're doing component not that I
do but the London system can be a little
crazy I think you should play e5 c5 just
play it go for it challenge the center
all right is that the normal line for
this right here was a pleasure playing
against you should swear M Steen shoot
Springsteen the London system sorry I'm
sure I butchered that name a bit I'm
Adrian from Darrow has been asking for a
game for a while what is your name on me
chess so my good friend and associate
Danny Machuca teaches his students the
London system and
I've been harassed for a year and a half
by this London system so unfortunately
we have more people that want to play
games than time to play games so we will
not be able to get to everybody oh gosh
you don't have any internet reconnecting
yes it's not the HDMI cable it's the
Internet and why am I so dark
why cause like the Internet's going in
and out like your power source is gonna
do something because yeah power is going
all over the place and all of our
devices we might be like overloading the
strip or something am I like hitting the
power strip is there like a very loose
power strip cable or something
[Music]
I will try to accept as much of your
challenges as I can crying all the time
is too limited I does it display them in
crying a lot of scores although it's a
bad move coping and I'm sorry honey
that was a bad move you know that Bishop
was hanging yes it was Oh No
what's going on why am i frozen frozen
oh you are frozen why are we frozen
Danny we live who knows we live we
frozen there you go okay Queens being
that loose Queen don't lose Queen should
I take that pawn what happens at least
you have a bishop attacking be one so
it's like hard form to put a broker
there I mean it's still kind of scary
business a little scary you're up a
piece you don't do anything crazy have
we thought about green screen green tree
might be fun but uh we have such a nice
studio already oh no I'm going to get
crushed the köppen and says don't lose
faith help keep fighting you know I'm
liable to blunder at any time copán in
so don't you worry just keep fighting
just keep fighting sorry we didn't get
to you Muhammad magdi hopefully we can
see you guys see you tomorrow and you
can probably the grandmasters were to be
here I'll try to remember your name to
make sure you get played tomorrow just
keep fighting copening if you are frozen
let it go and if frozen in it get it and
we're frozen again what's going on Danny
yeah we just keep getting all kinds of
the third game in a row that I'm gonna
win and it's for frozen but we're live
here we go finally all right here we go
I don't know if it's like chess it so if
my but my internet unlike the chats
gonna
I'm going in as well who knows yeah I
don't really know what else to do either
but we're good we're doing great
business just moved is night in your
face I even wanted to stay there or are
you gonna hockey okay doesn't mean
hockey means a check so I should not say
that you guys go over the schnitz
opening used by gia [ __ ] opening assets
in world champion 1984 I'll have to
recommend that to Jim McCloud our nose
Allah the Lord is why are you using
studio lamps the light is better so the
better quality we are using studio lamps
but I thought we had been using them the
whole time maybe we forgot to turn them
on one day and it was ugly
that day you were watching before No Oh
some streams were just with the webcam
but is probably still these lights but
it's the worst camera probably depends
I'm Emily are you I'm manly manly yes
too close in Europe the internet is
freezing all over the place they need to
put some antifreeze in the internet
pipes so that it doesn't freeze you
double up your books you can bring your
knight towards the senator challenges
that just weaken my Jeep on but I am
great actor cringe pawn at Eric Eric
made some cringe puns oh I get it I get
I get the joke Navin good job good Eric
Rosen and Penguin online - what are we
doing why can't the work we're friends
with them what's so funny Eric Rosen is
a nice person he's a very nice man
okay I guess you don't want to trade so
I want to see I just ran splaying csgo
by the way yes for free now
I've never go it's like the precursor to
Cod it's the it was the shooter that
made shooters popular hello Nick risk Oh
Nick risk Oh what's going on Nicholas
don't think you got to sneak in three in
a row risk oh look at us go Peter oh
I've won three in a row can you believe
it except for frozen again okay then
we're not time's going alright good
I haven't got a compliment from the lava
lord I know and from Jonathan France
I know coping in he says oh no I went
across technical office assault I never
see my queen what are you doing Conan
there's a birthday wants to see me on
shooter games but notice these glasses I
have very bad vision shooter games are
not easy shooter games but Nick play a
game oh my goodness who said that
vampire chicken fire chick vampire
chicken I've won three in a row
alright is Lama Lord a part of your
chess club in st. Louis I believe that
is for him to reveal and him and him
alone
bad vision is better than box vision
what are you going on is that just like
you put your head in a box and you can
only see out the holes
this guy's well that's a very in-depth
analysis Nick that was great let Nick
play a game Nick will make you look good
can I finish off this game first please
we must know our viewers I would love to
play Mauro wins I've I've tried to get
some of those old games working but I
need to like fix all the mods and make
them actually work I'm just gonna play
Bishop g6 after this because he's
annoying me right now hey I've got a
cheer from from Joe zero 1095 thank you
very much Joe welcome welcome to have
you
dottie dad's donation earlier today so
thank you for the hundred bits as well
dotty dad pleasure to have you here
thank you and we're gonna trade llama
Lord reveals that he works for the Chess
Club and that they in fact pay him to be
here
true true statement memberships for the
Chess Club are for kids there are ten a
month fifty a year and then for adults
it's 15 a month 100 for a year and then
with the membership what you get is you
get to know if you're an employee you
don't need a membership with the
membership what you get is it's similar
to you know a gym membership you get you
know access to the facilities you get to
come in and go to all of our classes for
free we have lots of classes every week
being able to get Grandmaster level
instruction for priceless free after the
membership you know you're paying a
hundred bucks a year to come to
thousands of hours of Grand Master
lectures that's a pretty good rate
hunting
what shall I play
another tax upon that goes and he can't
play right here because my strong bishop
is um anything right at him
do you have to be at a certain level to
be an employee no you do not have to be
Nick works here yeah Nick works here so
you didn't realize what room you were
stepping into Nick keep your pawns
pretty keep them pretty I'll take what's
this guy yeah yeah for a whole year
that's a pretty good deal um we're
really just trying to promote chess
we're not really trying to make money
off of Jeff oh we just love chess just
love the game okay that is a great
diagonal for your bishop he just keeps
coming
[Laughter]
that really weakens your King a lot good
job technical team fast on the uptake ah
oh yes good job Danny we're so proud of
you guy inbox salutes you
are you guys hiring um I don't know
who's this Danny and does he play chess
Danny does play chess a figment of your
imagination is awesome he does not exist
on this plane oh thanks for joining us
El Cid lis ID have a good time at the
gym Oh force the Queen trade isn't the
rule in the French to always retreat I'm
fine good would be mad oh he used to
play the French all the time you sound
like a coward
he quit playing the French came to the
center and then have a bishop and he
won't there's like no way for you sir
good game good game
yeah move your king over to that side
take a trade pawn straight on straight
on straight pawns yes no and now you
only trade a few pushes good game
counterfeit all right get in there all
right all right good game guys don't hit
the Mike a lot with your hand cause it's
really loud about it okay good job Danny
[Music]
GG Perry you are loved
Navan loves you Navin 7:28 TD
Oh Oh could you grab me a Red Bull yes
who knows how many viewers we have I'm
interested we got like a hundred on
YouTube and we got like a hundred on
Twitch I wonder if it's the exact same
100 bots on both alright
Thank You Jonathan
alright you ready to get crushed
maybe pressures on like everybody is
watching I know this is very intense
viewbots confirmed indeed that's the
only way to get any viewers please link
your youtube sure I will link what you
to our YouTube thank you sir
here is our youtube link you can watch
us on youtube as well us earlier
challenges our chronological yes they
are so I assume the means on top is on
top is the oldest alright so always
let's let's establish a policy of always
clicking on top okay come on like 100
plus people would actually watch a chest
stream exactly oh by the way these these
names here are now reversed I'm this guy
I'm that one and then Nick is this one
right here the end friends also we're
friends now oh I guess I just committed
to something I wasn't ready my fear of
commitment is coming out strong wait is
this the chest stream I don't know yes I
thought it was just me hanging out
stream apparently we're also playing
chess okay I mean we can switch to lead
jobs if we want mm-hmm introduced Nick
with his chess trading please what is my
blitz is like 1650 only chess
alright blitz is blitz only chess is
like 1650 yeah yeah we talked about
vampires and chickens and llamas and
worms and worms oh is gonna make Captain
Zork not a bot cannot confirm
that's exactly what about would say in
Europe it's very late
so most to watch the videos tomorrow
well I'll be happy to watch them
tomorrow
[Music]
I am NOT a bot I'm a box I could be
alive don't you usually put bots in
boxes
all right make sure to open this little
away from Mike oh yeah I saw having the
other day yeah it was pretty spicy why
was this held I'll allow that message
from guy in box 1200 and real life
well my over the board blitz is 800 but
it's been a while since I've done it oh
do we have we have a wolf at the Chess
Club well isn't isn't our AV guy the
chess playing wolf I know we've got all
kinds of animals we've got lots of
animals that play chess and one drunk
lifeguard what does it mean when you
have a question mark after your rating
that means that you haven't played
enough games to get say an official
rating you're braiding is still
provisional so while you have the
question mark your rating will jump a
lot more got a lot more variability a
lot those only chess it's about 26 games
if it's not all one result I think that
sounds like the world's best zoo I agree
isn't Red Bull unhealthy yes but it
keeps me awake sleeping would also be
healthy sleeping is for the weak who's
she sleep who she I never knew her okay
Nakamura that's pretty healthy probably
outpost Nakamura I love whatever
Nakamura comes to town because then we
have infinite Red Bull it's great yeah
this looks not losing I don't think
you've lost yet I think I'd rather be
white but not buying like a lot I mean
yeah I mean Black has more more time
what does have more time that is like 30
seconds so let's just hope yeah I've
heard of this yerba mate a I I want to
try it out but uh the club has red bowl
for free so that is another thing to
consider where do I go you couldn't
attack a rock with a pickup I could yeah
it's kind of spicy was it Jesse cry when
he was here was they play with your ugly
pieces yeah maybe your ugly pieces and
make them pretty don't play with your
pretty pieces Oh your tryst Club is a
five hour drive for me do any of these
super gems give a lecture that guests
can attend for a single entry fee yeah
we have well also two things for you
protein one we have out of what do they
call it non-local membership they call
non-local memberships so if you're more
than 50 miles away you get everything at
half off so an annual membership for you
would only be fifty but also if you made
the drive there's also day passes so a
day pass for a kid is three dollars for
an adult is five dollars and first day
is free so yeah your first visit to the
Chess Club is always free so you can
come check us out
um see if you like our club see if it's
worth the drive for you
oh yeah rip queen Hey Wow we'll be
missed
yeah that was I'm from Scotland which is
that the same rate it's a bit of a drive
yeah all right well you know what they
say when you're a queen down oh yeah
when you're a queen down you start
that's when you start that's when you
attacked pieces I mean maybe you'd yeah
maybe you can get like some night back I
have a 15 hour flight from my city well
if you flew here I will all personally
wave your first day visit you know I'll
make sure you get into our club and come
to a lecture
Poland is nice I bet Switzerland's nice
this guy really knows how to pick a
stick and commit yeah he is committed
he's doing well hey no I get a what if
he pins your thing and then it's just a
rip trade he still has more Queens than
you well I guess your thing is defended
by a bishop
my thing is defended by a bishop so so
if he pins you take he takes you take
you're gonna have Queen all right okay
you got a you got a win with these pawns
well I mean I would take that pawn stone
well though he takes my pawn and then
this pawn so what if you take the pawn
and then move your rope behind the other
pawn that does seem like an idea and
then your bishops like defending the
queening square like maybe you have some
chances here is kids under 12 or what I
don't know oh it's scholastic its it's
all scholastic it's if you have a
student membership it's not kids its
students my mistake so anywhere up
through college if you have an online
idea or if you have a student ID you get
the discounted rate I meant to say
students not kids sorry if I missed info
is there any online lectures so we don't
currently do lectures live we might be
looking into that but what we do do is
we we're starting to premiere our
lectures on YouTube and I saw that was
on our twitch chat so I'm gonna go ahead
and just link our the homepage of oh
gosh not this one oh goodness I
and I'm gonna go ahead and just link our
YouTube channel and twitch chat in a
moment here and then you'll be able to
see that there are thousands of lectures
so many lectures more lectures than you
could watch in a lifetime so that's our
YouTube channel you can go there you can
see lots and lots of lectures definitely
check out Jonathan's check out VARs
check out the officer Sara Juan's Ben
Feingold has an amount of decent
lectures on there as well I would
suggest against it I don't know it's
kind of hard for him to like checkmate
you though dude you have like stuff
there's lots of a lot sir
boy exactly to do like nothing you need
to do nothing there's the high I could
just try to blitz them up make sure to
hit the subscribe box hey that also
helps us out as well Isaac is the young
man with the beard in as well I'm I'm
I'm this guy no not Nick wait there
right there that's me
nick is the and friends
Oh what's Isaac's rating also I'd like
to know the rating of the guy with the
food in his beard that sits next to him
oh I hope I don't have any food in my
beard it's maybe I did but I haven't
eaten any oh you moved your bishop off
of that diagonal well it was supporting
the pawn but I wanted to support the
pawn from the other side it looks like
we're gonna win on time here know if you
play fast enough yeah totally earned
that victory ya know yeah and then you
just play faster than okay that red ball
really carried you through that's right
nick is the best and I never doubted him
good job
vampire chicken Thank You vampire
chicken that really made my day
Wow our our auto mod is very because it
is very sensitive it didn't like the
term duck in Danish huh just trying to
say what the word duck is in Danish but
auto mod didn't want it to happen but I
permitted it you are allowed sir next
talk about ducks duck sir oh that's what
you're playing too but though doesn't
that oh that's Spanish for duck right or
no is Spanish Pavo play I barely know
the rules that's all the way down here
yeah we got we got to go make it to you
we're gonna keep going from from the top
um we've there you are hey good job I
like that hey we're gonna get a nice
paavo equals Turkey okay he plays this
move this move I have seen this movie
before
are there any classes tonight today is
Wednesday right today thank you sir yeah
today is Wednesday so we have the adult
beginner class and we will soon have
Caleb Denby teaching the road to 2000
but I don't think he's doing it today I
think today is just the adult beginner
class Isaac can you talk to me hello
Andre to door welcome to welcome to our
stream how Red Bull tastes like gasoline
gets you going accurate accurate really
gets the people going it's uh oh there's
also the end game class tonight at 7:30
there will be two lectures tonight at
the club the beginners class like you
know just after learning the pieces what
what should he start doing next at 6:30
and then there's the engine class at
7:30
well I'm world of I don't know what's
going on I I feel like they could have
taken advantage that my night wasn't
protected by the Queen anymore
Oh crunch Jersey Perry you done for
Bishop is hanging and so is the pawn be
able you take the bishop with us
Pondexter we do this and protect the
pond with a it's like a little
unfortunate to play but it's not bad I
don't could be worse
yeah I mean the queen is not I started
playing chess after watching Isaac's and
yo sirs YouTube videos great content you
must mean Jonathan's because I don't
think I'm on our YouTube channel
no I am I interviewed I did I did in one
interview that's all it does but
microphone you qualified oh yeah
qualified I was unqualified I'm not on
that
am i no mics the interviewer unqualified
I was the interviewer for that one like
Scholastic tournament promotional video
I interviewed Kareem that was the name
of that guy Kareem was a good man cream
was a lot of fun to go out with
us let's do it with the bishop hear us
low teens love doubling up of rooks it's
great Kareem the dream indeed we miss
Kareem come back green wait I went out
with a man yes and I felt no shame you
need to move move move your queen so you
and I can go there and if your night
ended up on the d-4d for that might not
be bad yeah it looks like the name of
maan amitin was mentioned all right yeah
I know him he's a chess player yes yes
well on twitch always you can like go
back like five days or something is
automatically recorded this is a world
of hurt things have gotten how do you
say constricted questionable I don't
feel completely losing other than just
my time you're certainly not completely
losing but your position looks a lot
harder to play accurate pin so let's fix
that where do you want to push that the
night can't take you take okay supports
this for this black has a lot of c-file
control and we can't really get any
rooks on there to do anything about it
all you need to put a rook maybe you
need to play Brooke fx1 rook F 1 and
then Knight e 2 many of so many things
defending that that that rookie down
there but if he trades fish up into it
it could be bad news actually in between
yeah that's like that's a good in
between er yeah
you're fine yeah I said I was good
you're doing fine let's put all of your
pieces on the second-ranked
yeah I would just play rough - King H
doops you just decided to hang both of
them I decided to be generous yeah
you're done for you yep
that was a good Intermezzo but not good
checkmate him play rook rook over and
over up over he doesn't have any
immediate Lee you're just gonna cry
no I'm not gonna cry I mean I would yes
yeah actually I'm gonna cry hey actually
maybe not take the pond oops
no you can because the Queen was funny
all right tragic that's fine
good Mannix do they do these things
regularly at the st. Louis chess club as
of last week yes you can see our stream
schedule down there for this down there
so today is Wednesday we stream to 3
p.m. today tomorrow we'll have the GM in
residence so if you want to play a
grandmaster make sure to join us
tomorrow ok and if you want to see Mike
comer play on Friday he is certainly the
most it's crazy how similar Isaac's
voice is with Jonathan's if you close
your eyes it's hard to tell which is who
indeed so we have lots of similar
cadence and stuff as well because
growing up I thought my brother was
really funny so I tried to imitate him a
lot and so I ended up like him was mr.
Frantz doing so far what's the score I
don't know I went like 50/50 is Yasser
still the GM and residence no no he is
usually GM and residence during the US
Championship and during the Sinquefield
Cup Ferno right before those because he
usually does the announcing for those so
he typically comes in those GM and revs
for the month or so before the US
Championship and before the Sinquefield
Cup
only please blitz over one game awesome
I asked you sir whether he spends more
time in America or Amsterdam where his
house is
and he said it's about 50/50 nice
what are the chances of Fabi being the
GM in residence very small he's got
bigger fish to fry
gonna say I think he rather you know win
chess tournaments and make lots of money
instead of getting paid a decent amount
of money issue well actually no because
there's a chance we could get him to do
hear a lecture to or something like that
though I think it'd be fun to have Fabi
do a lecture for us what if certain 95
90 which is next turn 8 and when is he
going past Magnus I don't know this next
tourney is good I assume he'll be
playing in the u.s. championship at
least so that's in starts a little bit
earlier toward the end of March this
year nice probably playing something
before that no he took the problem for
me these games going to be analyzed
later no they are going to be thrown far
away from anybody's eyes so they can
never be seen where's Mike yeah John cor
disco join us in 48 hours
and Michael be here and Mike's mic
streams are the one that never end here
yep Mike likes to stream for hours on
hours on hours on hours and hours
because it's more fun to stream than
work can we get Mike plus GM stream
unlikely because all the GM's hate them
joe-joe by the way may be possible yeah
taking is never forced I don't know I
don't know if the internet can handle
that
of content though you know we might
overload the system we might crash the
entire internet I don't if we had Mike
Ben Feingold and an actual GM oh that
would be glorious
I feel like that was a waste to move our
feeling all right
I'm I'd be so afraid it'd be so afraid
how about you play one more game after
this one more no why because I want to I
have actually work to do I mean I guess
you could house STL ever associated with
Sam Shanklin didn't we just put out a
bunch of videos yes sure
I mean associated with like not
I mean he's come here and given lectures
he's never he's not like a sponsored by
us or a part of the organization or
anything he did when the u.s. champ suit
here I don't think we've ever done
anything with Jeffrey Zhang anything
he's done any lectures I think he's just
come here and crushed people he does a
certain amount of crushing people and
making them cry I'm looking at s no
desire to improve on these games I see
these games are mostly for entertainment
value yeah we wanted to improve if I
would just do thousands of tactics
that's pretty much the only way I've
learned to do any chess
who has time for getting better at chess
it's so hard all you do is replace your
pawns with bishops and you get better at
chess
see you tomorrow Navin it was a pleasure
to have you write files all this chess
is getting in the way of you getting
better at League it's true
so is Magic the Gathering arena I've
been playing that all night trying to
get cards that's not it's not chess but
it's fun what if you do six
what if you push pawn forces night away
and then push your other part so you
like that nice that's what I was
thinking and your Knights defended by
the bishop everything is all hunky-dory
see that that's why you don't do that
you know what what if we you're Queens
attacked I know but what if we that's
not well because then he just takes your
night and he's still attacking your
queen yeah know what we go here all
right all right getting frisky with it I
like it give them that guys that guys
well maybe you needed to go somewhere
where your queen was still touching that
night so that if he takes the pawn it's
hanging well true yeah maybe maybe a
rookie to see no no you got two things
attacking that no II to see or see the
aide to see a to see who knows man no
all right instead of learning chess next
I'm going to learn I'm going to learn
the alphabet
well he's got pawn and some weed you
still have a queen though whatever that
is Queen it just say wait gross
it looks like I'm winning something you
know I think yes I believe you are
borderline crushing yes only borders on
I just don't like get your bishops don't
losers I might give my Queen away again
I've seen you do before I wouldn't be
surprised you can attack a rookie and
upon know that you can't attack a look I
wonder what problems you should go for a
light switch protecting the king darks
would be the best first thing in magic
to act to get an actual full deck I do
not have any cards what should i buy
first I have found that I started with
mono green I had about enough to make a
decent deck but I hear that mono blue is
the most cost-efficient deck to make
because he's gonna go here maybe you
need to get your queen maybe two maybe
maybe you need to I don't know what you
need to do something
what should you buy first yeah mono blue
that's the easiest way to climb on a
blue clay constructed events and you'll
you'll do nothing but make profit this
isn't fun I'm understanding what the
word hurt means
how much is it well MTG Arena is free
and you start with n amounts of cards
you can almost make hey Richard another
MTG fan you can almost make a really
good cheap amount of blue deck just with
what you start with
so I mean you you could be winning games
in twenty minutes from now you know if I
can trade the Queen for both rooks I'm
still not completely losing I would do
that Richard play Richard you want to
believed you want to play some games on
our stream why would we let Richard he
plays chess yeah that's probably a
little bit worse than you do you ever
play on chess comm Isaac all right I do
not well I guess I do sometimes if I'm a
little inebriated I like to because
Miley chess name is drunk lifeguard but
I only play sober then my my chest calm
name is Esau would which is Spanish for
Isaac and I play on that one drunk what
over six well that's what I play all
right
see you never have a good night we won't
do a brown felt birthday have a good
time of day but Queen's Indian this is
all I know of the Queen's Indian what
was that last game I want in time no you
want in time yeah so this is as much as
I know
we're just gonna develop and not hang
anything oh no my queen the same no he
gave me the file
that makes me not sound that makes me
happy this position looks pretty decent
no huge advantages for either side you
got it you got it I got the I got the
file this is fine this is fine has your
house burns down the fire is the Queen's
Indian defense better than the Kings
Indian who knows they're I think they're
just too different to give a good
response
all I know is I don't study openings I
just play moves that I've memorized and
then trying to do tactics yeah that is
the key to getting that's not good
because that I mean definitely move your
night I can get behind that I can get
behind that
chefs website do you consider the best
all right like I like Lee chess the most
I just like the interface the most and
the such but if I paint his night as no
his ladies no pens I dare him to take
that bishop pin attacked pieces
I love BOGO Indian with black BOGO and
you love to buy one get one free India
yeah yeah
Bishop II something there should be five
defends the night for now they should be
something but then this oh right
just kidding that night would take it
this might be good news for us I think
[Music]
well we decided to be down in exchange
then a piece which I can't disagree with
two heartedly where can this night go
this night can't go anywhere can it so I
just attack it that that was that was a
good thought yeah
I agree race Jones opening theory is for
squares well it's all about studying
tactics that is almost a pun opening
theory is for squares and he resigns
that was a good good try good try but
God be careful with waste pieces on the
phone yeah yeah whenever your Knights
get way into their territory it's hard
to get them out all right
this will be the last game one more
Perry hasn't taken enough of a beating
today he needs more sorry headphone
users all right you're good
five challenges here it's chess960 of
the future maybe they're fun tournaments
though senior board all right
1877 it's gonna be a tough challenge for
old Perry Perry is on fire today go fire
you Perry you might want to put that out
that looks painful telling you is gonna
play you for he does know our screen is
gone or screen is gone no no come back
way back
no we're not I got this we back yet
we're back we're good
are we yes no we're not there you know
even what you talked about okay thank
you
there were 81 thank you guys there we go
Thank You Isaac
big battle of the seniors coming up
senior a board won and Perry call today
watch this Kings Indian watch this what
is a Kings Indian excuse me Queens
Indian watch this watch this
yeah that opening was too crazy we had
to censor risco playing Bishop e7 and
then c5 thanks for joining us guy in box
we will make sure to box them all in for
you that's funny he has a boxing glove
and a box that's great
oh we're frozen again losing time yeah
yep that's things to be you yeah it does
make sure to adjust that Mouse again
that'll that'll fix that yes the opening
lectures my brother on YouTube are great
cool this is not cool we're losing time
probably hello Sid the sloth we are in
fact epic and now we are at that Thank
You Sid now something's wrong with our
internet though no we're doing great
this only happens to you by the way oh
my gosh oh my gosh good thing it was on
his clock we will see you next time guy
in box this is going to be likely our
last game of the game cuz Perry has a
lesson I have videos to edit not
technical directors and editors got to
do things we have other media it might
be a leech s issue but I don't know it's
possible
stay tuned tomorrow Mike comers brother
challenges the world not true and it's
baked news w Bennett what's going on
tomorrow we have GM Dennis Boros playing
some chess and yeah sorry Sonny we
you'll probably out a challenge us
tomorrow tomorrow we'll have the
Grandmaster playing so join us tomorrow
at or 3:00 p.m. Central Time and play
the Grandmaster I just miss challenges
by one or two excruciating sorry protein
just take that um try and make sure you
get a game tomorrow trying displaced but
I'm frozen again you should stop
freezing I just sit down yeah go fast
cuz you'll never know when you're frozen
again just happen every time you make a
move yes but like I'm my Internet's not
going down so I think it it must be a
bad karma or something
yeah I'm I still have internet I don't
know what's going on by you move your
ugly pieces
maybe you want to put a rook on to eat I
don't know except from frozen again
Barry you got it you just gotta let it
go
Barry Barry I won four in a row I just
want to let the audience know that you
want to build a snowman
I bet you flag because you lose ten
seconds to move for any reason for no
good reason
tragic a well-played game sou h-hi
representing do something is there an
extra H in there is that slew hi hi
I don't think Perry's understood a
single frozen reference since the time
you've begun he just laughs awkwardly oh
the movie frozen it appears you were
correct the proteins all my children are
older now okay all my children are
beyond the Disney movie age so I've lost
touch and I've lost some time because my
clock was frozen
yep so that's unfortunate yeah kind of
what kind of a weak game to go out on I
suppose we just call it a day either way
as if we're gonna keep freezing that's
not going to be fun for the viewers or
us our viewers our players thank you
everybody for joining us on in on the
games and Lee chess and a chat I think
we have guys from charter here they're
doing all kinds of stuff yeah let's just
return tomorrow and now the GM's gonna
do this Esther it's a special shout out
to Dottie dab for the hundred bits and
jo0 10 for the 95 any much you could in
the bar thanks Danny
all right see you next time all right
you can do it Danny
hit the button oh you're over there any
with chuka he's a legend I forgot he had
a lesson